hey guys it's Jonah here do you consume
Jam on a daily basis I like to spread my
toast with peanut butter and jam and
sometimes I like to top my overnight
oats with jam it adds that extra
sweetness to my morning so a lot of
store-bought jams are usually loaded
with sugar if you were to look at the
ingredients list sugar is usually listed
as the number one ingredient and it is
definitely not a healthy option so why
not make your own healthy Jam instead it
is so simple with only three basic
ingredients fruits chia seeds and any
sweetener of your choice so these jams
have no refined sugar no artificial
ingredients and it's 100% natural if you
have been following my videos you will
know that I love chia seeds I have been
adding chair seeds into my water and
drink them on a daily basis chassé it's
a loaded with essential nutrients such
as potassium magnesium iron and more
they will also help you to stay fuller
for longer now because chia seeds would
absorb up to ten times their weight in
water they are a great natural gelling
agent and also thickener so you wouldn't
even need pectin to make these jams I'm
gonna share with you three of my
favorite fruit jams mixed berries mango
and peach to measure the fruits into two
cups each you can choose to either use
fresh or frozen fruits then place the
fruits into a small pot over medium-high
heat then mash the fruits until it
reaches the consistency you like I like
to have some fruit chunks in my jam at
this point you can choose to sweeten it
with two tablespoons of honey or maple
syrup this is optional then simmer for
about five minutes until it forms a
saucy consistency remember to stir
frequently add in two tablespoons of
chasity
and continue to stir for another minute
until all ingredients are well combined
remove from heat let us sit for about 10
minutes to allow the chasis to fully
expand thickening the jam the jam will
continue to thicken as
who's down at this point if you like
your gym to be thicker you can add
another teaspoon or two of chia seeds
and again let it sit for another 10
minutes pour into a jar and your jams
are ready store in the fridge and this
will keep fresh for up to two weeks
these chair jams are looser and more
sauce like compared to the traditional
store-bought jam you can use it just
like a typical jam so spread it on toast
stir into oatmeal or spoon it over
yogurt how do you like to have your gem
let me know in the comments below so go
and grab your favorite fruits and make
your own Jam okay don't buy any stock
jam because it is so simple so be sure
to try this recipe out take pictures tag
me at international official and hashtag
it chase the recipes because I want to
see your creations also do like this
video share this video and subscribe to
my youtube channel for a lot more
healthy recipes workout videos and also
fitness tips guys do turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I upload a new video
all the best